hello and welcome to this video playing
news oh and we won't get an Enzo we won
see form preventing this quite reliably
ok so I'm going for a quickie before him
let's see if nums o is playing with f5
one without it's a big decision Wow
don't see that often if I then is not
taking wow ok a bit of a surprise ok so
not unhappy about this time gains
interesting okay I'm Catholics cannot
really be wrong oh now that that's not a
move I expected it's an interesting move
Knight to c5 is what he wants to do ya
want you trade him and trade trade trade
um yes but you have not cancelled yet
mr. names oh so I'm look up here right
full look
rock is a rock I actually blundered that
I was thinking you could to see for but
ok so what's the deal we should have one
is gone night c4 maybe you know so still
the right move ok so i'ma take it here
need to make sure that it's not getting
too many passports this is running into
a walk threatening a book takes b5 now
here or take sand would be five yeah
root b 5 is probably pretty and pretty
clean nightly to Queenie to the rock is
protected and here takes Bishop takes
wins the Queen and up out for 96 95 and
so on so I um change that into being a
piece up instead of a rock up chaplain
nights are fairly strong him
Bishop a form and then I'll take it his
pieces cannot do all that much
well
check I mean I don't really mind if they
play on it sometimes it's rather poor
choice of course check stalemates
stalemates please check don't even know
how to under promote you to be honest
how does that work okay make Jetts the
domain okay yeah in plundered the whole
house there in the opening a bit
surprising if you go a five you normally
want to take one before so that your
rook is scanning some scope but she
didn't you didn't do it I mean not that
this is terrible for black but just a
very unconventional way of doing it okay
five I castled you form yeah okay that's
a normal move I actually think that
before isn't all that great because well
we saw 95-94 is good for white and I'm
going to bust open the position in like
this i'm going to go d3dx9 a form and
something like that is pretty nice for
wider yeah he went here I would actually
I actually missed something Knight takes
e4 is stronger huh yeah this idea that's
pretty good I mean yeah I'm better but
not winning 94 I was winning yeah but I
came
he went 93 he has to take now and i was
i was actually planning this kind of
thing okay here white this is better
this is just a good bishop here night
comes here and so on but okay the way it
weighed when he was done everything yeah
it was pretty stupid blunder to pause
here and somehow thought he has to go
back to c4 and then things open up it
okay look up is a bit too much can you
check return some stuff and yet so
fairly easy win ok guys thanks for
watching